for the thousands in attendance and the
millions watching around the world this
is the main event
dildo core is alive and kicking
come on over here I'll hit but your ass
a couple times interrupts and I hope I
didn't piss off Jesus it's the LA
Clippers they just called in hangs up
he's not a contest he be James you're
stupid idiot
forget so [ __ ] up tightly it got that
letter B line - clearly
what's up [ __ ] faces welcome to a new
episode of punch-drunk
anything so I'm triangle sillier
absolutely go I also want to go more
serious like hello everyone and welcome
to punch-drunk because a lot of podcasts
do that kind of move where it's like
real a lulling voice and there he is
ladies and gentlemen Samuel Gompers
Tripoli welcome welcome welcome so Tom
Brady was it is it official did he get
four or three there you go man four and
now the number one sleeper pick and
fantasy football has been defined for
James out for sure yep so people are
gonna you sleep on Tom you get your
Andrew Luck early and then once your
roster is kind of full you grab Tom
Brady when everybody forgot about him
and week five great trade babe no you
draft him late and you hold him hostage
for four games and then you see who
needs a [ __ ] quarterback we just
started you wanted to feel free to do
the business ladies gentlemen from Tampa
Florida Sam Tripoli
yeah good to be here guys how are you
it's happy to be here
good Cortland town our golf
correspondent yeah that's call for that
any of us know the best golfing comedian
in the world that should would you say
you're the best golfing comedian in the
world I don't know about that I'm
definitely in the top five well most of
the guys Cosby is in technically top
four top four yeah who's good who's good
who is good who's George Lopez good I
could kill Lopez what about golf
very good ProAm I'm probably gonna be
like yeah you're good
there are some guys that are pretty good
I'm trying to think like I want to stand
your santino Andrew Santino's decent
connell veteran is actually
knock Kyle Dunnigan but who's the guy
that had that had American Idol and then
quit Oh
Dunnigan doesn't cut long Brian
Dunkleman decent does a good Marcis that
odd decision in Hollywood there has to
be the worst decision in the history of
punches Ryan Seacrest worth not that he
could not technically go there because
it could be I would say buddy I would
say I would say that secret this is
easily worth a billion dollars a billion
I would be how I'll accept but as we
know he has his own production companies
as the Kardashians he has he has
everything I mean this guy's got to be
worth close to a billion dollars and
what does he spend it on a little
Dancing with the Stars for every now and
then he doesn't really spend money I
mean I saw him you into a car accident
ooh 300 million it's still a lot of like
when you get to talk about like all this
shitload of money
that's where people get lying Dunkleman
have not world 300 million dollars he's
not worth even close he's not worth know
he left no he he left you know no us
Brian Bulger he taught he tried to talk
him out of it hey he tried to talk him
out he's like Brian you can't Dunkleman
you can't do this is the worst decision
ever yeah that's this is why he wasn't
be able to talk him out of it because it
was not his decision well I think
renewed the contract everybody goes and
he goes he goes what the oh yeah man you
would the worst part you complained
every day
you weren't fun to work around we're
getting it everyone else in million
dollars a year and you're out
and so the humor us to release a
statement saying I don't want to come
back that's why I couldn't talk him out
of it cuz he didn't they didn't want
don't get Dunkleman on here I'm willing
the bag of bets this thing I'm willing
to say he'll still say what he said then
okay so if everybody involved says
that's not what happened you're gonna
stick to the story cuz you have an
insight juice scoop is evidence
only dumb inside that's not everybody
involved if you gave me any producer for
American Idol then yeah all right I'm
gonna get that fat like I I think
there's I think it's it's a it's a
hybrid of both what you're saying I
think he was such a [ __ ] pain and he
asked to work with that when they came
back oh Jesus
this is so uncomfortable breathe and our
dates out of the gates
ah guys check out check out caveman
coffee go to caveman coffee calm use
promo code punch drunk sports get 10%
off your coffee I got see if they owe
some cash coming up then also use bet
deicide bet the aside great sports over
the weekend a lot of stuff to make some
money off bet DSi used punch-drunk
sports calm and use punch-drunk and you
get 10% bet $10 bedding cash go to Oh
big news
punch young sports could've punctured
sports I come use the Amazon link and
get whatever the [ __ ] you want but
listen big news about party truck
sports.com
it's a widget now dyi you know who we
are we are now featured on Apple News we
are now part of their feet if you go on
our toes you'll be able to see punch on
sports feeds on that website I'm not
joining your girl hazard sure no I'm not
the skins today
yeah well he's not even on the camera
shave my back in a while so I'm just not
gonna say consignee looks like a
werewolf they took the clouds just
parted and they didn't he just saw the
full moon halfway through the song when
he changes yeah three minutes to turning
into a werewolf
let's do dates out of the gates
everybody Tebow the Apple watch is
coming out and it's gonna be a feed and
you could die yeah you ever got a
bleacher report no it's kind of but
they'd suck on it you know those feeds
they pick up certain websites and from
certain different people regularly yeah
yeah yeah well Apple News and they'll go
down the feeds and one of the feed one
of the stories in the feed was going to
be broken butthole blown out people from
Apple News are gonna be getting their
information from us and all of our
articles girl gets her butthole fingered
by a dog that's not what we do i and
that shows how much you go on that
[ __ ] website oh sorry oh a lot of the
week I'll be at an a a meeting tomorrow
Saturday and Friday I'll be at the Ice
House in Pasadena California
I'm trying to sound more like romantic
oh no yeah cuz I think that's gonna help
our I'll literate determinant Sam's not
familiar with the term romantic is that
a big word in the last week yes it is
ah be nice house this Friday night and
Sam might have a gig for me and on some
Saturday so and also go to your naughty
show I plugged that on enjoy Diaz's
podcast last night perfect perfect when
I was on the dare court you got anything
you wanna shoot I have got my album my
CDs coming out tonight next Friday
August 7th it's available now on
pre-sale live from Pearl Street live
from the La Jolla comedy oh that's
awesome
yeah I did mine from their jaw it's the
[ __ ] greatest I love ya I got that
and then Friday night I am at the Comedy
Store with the all things comedy podcast
oh that's awesome man awesome fun
because I pulled out I think who did I'd
if somebody pulled out that's why I
guess that's the only reason I ever see
somebody polisher in the discussion yeah
well you know when you bag and piss and
moan every now and then you get in the
discussions by god damn it you know you
would just shut the [ __ ] up we'll let
him do it
we all can't be re and they all yea
blonde with big tits to get invited
everything if I was here I'd suck his
dick your areolas are uneven though
weird
you've got this belty body looks it's
like the most discussed they're uneven
look that the left side is lower than
the right side this is really weird wait
you see how stupid a belt is what is
your takes out of the gate sir let's get
through them all right bunny hop across
like bunny hop like Bing Bing come bunny
yeah I set it off I give you the gags
but you you pushed it so farther you got
me already just spread his [ __ ]
completely open and all but sat on the
camera of his computer I've officially
done gay porn I've officially done gay
porn that look like a kangaroo robbery
have you started watching your [ __ ]
at all no obviously not shampoo that
butthole and that's what we're both
telling you that yeah that's from a real
live werewolf break any dates all the
gates alright I'll be Corpus Christi
next week and then at the end of the
month I'm in La Jolla awesome oh I
forgot some real quick all I'm also
doing the comedy sour belly room now
that new material show that Yousef and
Rogan put together I'm doing that on
tomorrow night so if you saw this
Wednesday come to their belly room nice
what's up Ari got any dates buddy yeah
well tonight I got my storyteller show
at the creek in the cave and they have
added seats for if you want to watch
downstairs from just on a little screen
in the bar you can go do that for five
bucks but Edinboro anybody who's there
from like Scotland I need you to tell
everybody else that my show is the show
to go to so it's so it's full it's hard
to promote a show in Scotland so it's my
Saturday Sunday just so many shows so
many shows there's so many storytellers
shows so exists not happening till all
your friends are going to go to that
show and tell all their friends tell to
tell their can I give you some advice
dude this is serious wear skinny jeans
also flyers walk around and hand out
flyers but just make a piece of paper
that just says flyer on it that's it no
info no mitem I did Mitch Hedberg the
whole time I was there when I was
passing out flyers in Edinburgh I would
just go up to English people like oh
could you do me a favor and throw this
away for me and hand it to him and they
would go oh my god that's such a funny
thing and they would actually look at
the flyer they never came to the show
but they would look at the flyer that's
a start though that does start yeah
anything else are you Anne Burrell
that's pretty awesome your festival
[ __ ] yeah ah I have aa guest six
it's the naughty show at the W Hollywood
Hotel in the loft Joe Rogan Steve
Rannazzisi
Tiffany Haddish la weeklies number one
burlesque troupe
miss Dakota and lace dolls and uh DJ Joe
ah
Grado so it's gonna be a great show that
is it's gonna be uh it's available on
ticket fly we're exclusive would ticket
fly so go to TIG fly calm put the
naughty show grab your tickets and then
on the following two days I'm at
flappers Saturday I might have a gig for
you that Saturday so that's you're out
that sounds of great Sam so go check it
out man so that's it dates how the gates
lots to talk about lots two hours of the
festival how was Montreal pretty fun
pretty fun lot of [ __ ] going on saw some
cool shows the roast battle is what
everybody's talking about I wrote for
like five of them I mean it was
literally like the talk of the fest and
everybody just destroyed each other
no but alive you'll destroy each other
so I did a tournament style so everybody
did one round this
so they have four guys the first day go
against four other people narrowed down
to four and then the second day a
different group of crop of a 4 verse 4 4
goes and then the next day the winners
went and the day after that 7 finals
that they have had the finals who want
it the whole thing really ran it from
start to finish there was no close
fights he was in he was just [ __ ] on
fire the entire time maybe had two jobs
didn't hit hard
who'd he take out first round turn up
Willie understand
Australia's biggest come yeah honey dude
took him down but he did it it wasn't
just like ah here's a joke and this it
is attitude of like this guy I'm
roasting is a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's awful
we all know he's awful here's a joke man
honey beats his wife Wow it's an awful
person
he's a bad comic what are we doing
really beat his wife no whatever the
jokes were right right you wanted that
whatever the jokes were it was it was
that attitude of like [ __ ] you the way
Silva Wanderlei would uh would uh yeah
back when five days prior whoever was
fighting him like you think you're gonna
take this streak away from me I'll
[ __ ] kill you
first round maybe Joe DeRosa second
round I forgot who he beat third round
and then Matt Broussard Tony Hinchcliffe
Dale Tony beat Luna on the first round
you know in I will restate in a week
performance by Tony was a b-plus okay
and he goes what's wrong with people is
like you're happy with b-plus it he goes
all right and then he lost in the second
round
Tatiana she take on what was the guy's
name the the Canadian guy that she lost
to in like a double overtime yeah
okay Jeffrey Wilson yeah I wrote you
Wilson be Ashley Barnhill nobody thought
that was gonna happen but Kay Trevor
came out of the gates on fire wanted it
and then he beat Tiana and second round
yeah I went to like double over you this
is the thing that finally gets the rose
petal on television I mean I don't think
it should be on television
why because they say nothing not nice
things medium for that I mean if you
think about money I guess it is but if
you think about this is what everybody
thinks about what if they had a roast
battle in outer space guys every when
they try to get the best Roasters on
that's like okay there's cents ahead of
time don't you put it on television then
you take out all the the really great
racist comments oh it's it's funny
hey perv you there you go screamed every
week yeah thank the pressure off it I
think every week it should just be on
the web so you can see it every week so
then so the guys can start getting know
to write it guys like hormones and
Hayes's peoples are noise like oh I
heard hormones on tonight
this should be a good one that guy's
always great you know get you once a
season like am i doing oh I'm supposed
to judge I know I'll get bumped soon
because now there's a big hit so now
I'll get bumped that's always have me
and me and uh
Bartnik are supposed to host in August
and I swear to God every time it happens
it's like ah well you know we're trying
to get this on television so then pause
here bar judging any comedy III
understand listen I have nothing
personally against her but she was like
a nice guy I mean I need to stand up
she's done she yeah Rosie that's not
good we all get we got twisted she had
30 minutes we all know this now she had
30 minutes before she got her sitcom
which was fine you know she was doing
something interesting she was doing a
housewife thing that's dirty great but
she stopped doing stand-up yeah show was
amazing but there's
pedestrian her last 15 minutes of our
special is her dancing no I I watched I
watched it was it was okay it was okay I
mean I thought there was some really
funny there's some really funny [ __ ] in
it yeah it's like I don't know how well
it to me it's like potty humor so I love
it yeah I love that kind of [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean it's there's some really
funny premise but it's not real right
right like they call what like the guy
kissed what's-her-name Hendrix the real
hot redhead with the big tits yeah like
her name on the show is chair like they
call her he's on the show yeah she's
like Christina Hendricks yeah yeah she's
like [ __ ] mad yeah guys I think she
has got watch this show I love that she
but she plays a man you know
she plays a maid and they call him
whatever they want to call Mike this
isn't your name from now on your name is
chair and so the whole time they just
call her chair it's great that's
Hollywood yeah gorgeous chick with the
giant cans yeah while a bunch of low
beta [ __ ] doesn't I watch him it I
love her she is the build that every guy
really wants people don't women don't
understand that and gay guys don't
understand that like straight guys know
we want [ __ ] melkor's [ __ ] milk or
a nice dick ass and thick ass thighs
sorry do you wouldn't you play Tampa
where do you play The Improv ersite
splitters
there was a to cancel it last year I
don't remember where it was I I got
called in last second to the tamp I was
with uh I got to do I did three threes
in six days man and I went to a punch
line with t-ball bunch of punch drunk
fans came out yeah David okay mom well
today was pretty packed
I met one of the writers for pleasure
who wrote the breakdown of the fight
we're gonna have him at him in Montreal
that was a funny funny article exactly
and he has you winning right guy won't
fight me did he watch stupid rules dude
I'm ready to do it this is what he does
he but it's part of his psychological
warfare
he danced around golf for probably a
year and a half and then beat by the way
until one of the greatest days of my
life was getting to it was around in a
golf cart with Triple E
while everyone else got shit-faced watch
you guy was a party behind us up the
golf course literally there's still
texting [ __ ] holes Caitlin's Jen
Sturgis said they will [ __ ] jello
wrestle before the fight it might be
what's it good for that with doing
things like this and a jump said the guy
who got all involved I haven't seen
Jen's sergers stand-up I really like her
she's cool she got us into NASCAR and
Cate Quigley is [ __ ] funny I don't
give a [ __ ] that girl's fearless I call
heard Katie eyes she walks in this up
crazy-ass [ __ ] and kills no you can't
take anything away from her which one
would you want to [ __ ] first just showed
his [ __ ] what are you talking about
this is awesome balls out no we saw the
place we saw the balls and if I could I
would you stay dude she I can only talk
for K quickly because I haven't seen her
forever
I haven't seen Jen stir but cake quickly
works on her and she's legit funny dude
I'm not lying for them what's wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with the main
thing people see from you being your
nudity there's nothing over using that
you're hot to get in and then if you
have a legit the [ __ ] [ __ ] the best
part the best part of all this is is Ari
I understand he's totally naked Thank
You Skype all right let's take this call
look how much you've been participating
in no I did it so much talk about
callback callbacks in Johnson also one
ethnic person you talked to
exactly we did on this story about these
guys with Sigma let me get the exact
story all right I'll take this power you
do it hello you're on the air with a
punch drunk who do we have clay clay
Matt clay Andrew Dice Clay guy got a
question to ask you to when you how you
been you listened to the show and you
think Aria is too misogynist so I like
that they dice
I got a dice man I got a question for
you oh I was talking to somebody they
they brought up that you had gone on
Jason Ellis's radio show recently on XM
he's there Australian DJ who's really
popular on a serious and uh
word is that you would only go on there
if he let your your kids band play and
he was talking about Howard Stern how he
told you to your face at Max's band is
wheels cooking anything special for you
for lunch over there today dice have you
seen re recently I try you staying away
from re are you still upset about how he
one time you went rifling through your
probably the 47th time I've heard this
story but it seems to get better every
time all right why are you rifling
through dice man's affairs
okay the guy's dead
yeah but one thing study Soto fair
riflemen guys talk to us about fish
what's going out the show time shows is
still a go is it is it move forward any
fun facts you could kind of break some
news here on the podcast
Bozek fish are he's like 40 but his
[ __ ] like how come you're Max's band
doesn't open for you at the Hard Rock
my apologies man I do do respect you at
least I know you don't have to go find a
glove this will be great
oh I can't wait dice yeah we'll go are
you are you are you a member of a
Country Club dice dice who's your caddy
let's I really want God you called in if
there's anyone who could talk about this
topic let's talk about Hulk Hogan
dropping and bombs getting pissed the
black guys are banging his daughter
which who didn't see that coming woof
yeah but that that's thick fat
everything about her she is black guy
kryptonite yeah 100%
well what's your take on that the
Hulkster dropping the end bombs yeah
yeah you are poly there's a lot of
people that probably that's your biggest
fear but you have no idea what that
feels like
we can't condone that we have one black
listener dude and ah Anthony Johnson
would be mighty offended blue it's a
comment oh he runs our fantasy leagues
which were taking its submissions for
fantasy football if you guys want to get
in it I'll hit up in Sactown blue on
twitter tell me you want to get in a I
guess that's that I'm already willing to
trade players right now
no we haven't even drafted yet
I guess Jason else went on Stern it was
talking about how he wanted dice on his
show but the only way dice would come
ons if he led his sons band play and I
like max I got none against him he's a
good kid and he uh he played in a Jason
L Spacely thought said he thought his
band sucked dices face and that's the
story okay you gotta you gotta yeah who
means that Jason Tebow that every single
every time you call dice real quick you
know you've had a bit of controversy
with with black people in your day what
happened the time you had to take the
bus
that's the short version of that I've
heard of seven-minute version if that
seems the buildups quite fantastic did
you get on the bus nice oh my god
goddamn bus drivers
well dice we love you please everybody
probably oh man
will we get Ari back well he hasn't seen
anybody look at their phone so I think
he will take our yeah because he it's
nothing you haven't been on your phone
he just can't see you yeah or he doesn't
like it when you get on your phone the
whole time all the time he's on his
computers Hospice hey I gotta ask Ari
abuse have you gotten a phone yet are
you still going with the the little uh
you still old school oh [ __ ] look at
that look at that unbelievable what Ari
is nut will not get a smartphone I'm
thinking about getting a flip phone to
you and say that those years now dude
I'm telling you right now but all you
got to do is the minute you get one you
will become so dependent on your friends
as Arya's because the minute Ari is
around you and he'll you soon as you
pull out your iPhone he goes uh can I
see that and then he'll just start
looking [ __ ] up and they'll start you
doing oh hey you do instant messages
do you get a lot of naked messages I've
never received one message on I just
want to get back what kind of so like
dude send you back they compared ball
sacks yeah girl show you pictures on
Instagram re I know that I've never seen
1d ever Instagram I mean it wouldn't
tell me if I had one re I hate to get
back to sports
even though sports podcast oh yeah you
were looking it up so what's up okay
Braves baseball game yes this is couple
looks like first base side okay outfield
there's a couple Beal behind him and
they're looking over this couples
shoulder and they see this girl texting
her friend Nancy and Nancy they discover
is a fake name for someone she's
cheating with cuz they're looking over
his shoulder they're seeing her texts
and she's texting it's like yeah I want
you to [ __ ] me or not I don't want you
to bend me over I want you to do all
this crazy [ __ ] to me
you don't worry about and so these
people sitting behind the couple they
write a note down and says your wife is
cheating on you look at her text
messages under Nancy and they hand it to
her and they go we can take screenshots
we have screenshots if you want them oh
my god Wow
the guy called them and said I'd like
those screenshots please and they sent
it to him said they haven't heard
anything else from them no no I just
fell off yeah off come on Diane tell
stories you know their needs that
somebody died okay here we go here's
some of the pictures um so they start
tweeting it - which is a married couple
in front of you but hos hos ain't loyal
so me and Lenna Lana Lana baby 8 exposed
them Nancy or mark here's a text I'll be
naked laying on the ground one of the
message read mark Alan I love something
something so much said another tax the
name of the top of screen was Nancy
Nancy is Mark Allen
you solve the mystery there what they
were rewarding note on the on the roster
sheet and handed it to him and said
sorry just thought you should know and
so uh what do you guys think of this
Finkle is Einhorn I think there's some
[ __ ] nosy-ass
stay the [ __ ] out of it so you're sorry
she was clever enough to name the
[ __ ] dude she's [ __ ] Nancy so that
when it shows up it just says message
from Nancy yeah and it won't show up the
text I mean everybody you got to be
smart enough to do that you don't have
an iPhone so you want understand neither
sorry yeah but yeah [ __ ] off you got it
get an iPhone I just I just I get it at
the same time but it's just like why are
you putting your [ __ ] business into
someone else's business yeah and if so
at least tell us what the [ __ ] happens
in the end yeah yeah yeah what happens
in please sell me that big please yeah
if you're listening and you were the
couple either being spied on or spying
call into the show let us know what
happened
we need ending to this story yes
definitely a probably war machine derp
guys UFC oh it's chicks well then I
understand yeah still mind sexed in
public yes don't mind your own [ __ ]
business message in public
what bunch of [ __ ] I mean you're
rolling the dice nah man you gotta keep
that game gotta keep that game writing
next to your husband at a [ __ ] super
PAC plays UFC one for one night I mean
you know what I was against it before
but the Braves do need a new ballpark if
the seats are that close yeah but you
also need one of those anti reflector
things on there so they so some [ __ ]
can saw you [ __ ] pay attention to the
[ __ ] game you're taking seats away
three [ __ ] to nosy [ __ ] and one
[ __ ] [ __ ]
are taking three seats away from a man
that wanted to watch a [ __ ] game
you're taking a picture of her putting
it on social media opening her up to pay
attention to the game [ __ ] that happened
at a movie theater everyone would be
pissed yeah but these consoles just
wanted to take in seats probably got it
from some dude they're sucking off
sideways like a harmonica I'm mad once
that [ __ ] not seen watch a game and
you're like Todd I'll suck your [ __ ] I
can't wait you spray your milk all over
my fun bags that counts texting I'm
kinda police what's the game [ __ ]
that's great Oh Ari UFC 190 do you give
a [ __ ] I do not top three other than
Rousey but you hear only Mexican let's
check it out so we have Rousey vs career
I gotta [ __ ] these names out sure now
you got Marsh readout god damn it no
Shogun Rua Shogun Rua vs. Antonio record
it's 11 and 9 what I can't believe 11
another Ronda Rousey's 1100 Beth careers
at nine oh no looks like a dude tough
little [ __ ] rose Rogan posted a
picture her the other day she looks
threaded she looks shredded and big and
like Oh what I can't believe is you gone
all the message boards how everybody's
okay with Ronda Rousey gonna fighting
miesha tate for a third time it's
amazing yeah that's exactly what it is
did you see her up cited anybody see her
tip
fell out at their last fight who Miesha
Tate yeah well good yeah I can see a
nipple it's amazing she offers a fight
gina carano at 145 why does
anyone see that this girl's ducking
cyborg I don't really care
I mean it's finally it is what it is but
just so funny when she's obviously
pulling a Floyd Mayweather and dodging
cyborg why will you fight Carano at 145
but not cyborg at 145 I know so she says
I would fight her at 145
because she's running that she's clearly
running 100% everyone's like why should
she have to run listen dude if this was
a guy we always say look at we always
say the the great fighter who is cleaned
out the division should move up a weight
class and fight better or down whatever
you possibly could make whether your
body would be well Frankie Edgar moved
down because he couldn't fight for a
title anymore at 155 that's the only
reason he moved down that happened for a
title at 145 you moved anyway moved up
it's just where you can make the weight
and she can make 145 so at that point
you're running let me ask you guys this
so would you date a chick that weighed
145 and could kick my ass I'm fat [ __ ]
why not I mean I like the anorexic chick
like I do what use would you bang a
chick that weighed one that was like
five alive nine and one she said I was
in love with Hendrix or whatever her
name is
yeah Christina hi hazard that is my way
that's like 125 way dude hurt it's a
loner 45 Wow how much does [ __ ] know
there's no way she's do you think anyone
buys this pay-per-view I don't see why
you would do it why would you want to do
the third fight well it's gonna last
what 45 seconds oh the you are the
Ultimate Fighter thing yeah that always
brings a fight at least the last
Ultimate Fighter C 190
the ultimate final lightly
I know the ultimate fighter Brazil for
bantamweight final well that's not
Ultimate Fighter us I must be hot that
must be Brazil so Americans don't give a
[ __ ] about that several of them 161
pounds that's not too big enough I wait
a minute I do have a weight limit like I
don't know man that's under 50 of that
is tits by the way that's um yeah okay
guys if it's 110 yeah we're under yeah
80 pounds that had his tits and ass if
you're my weight limit if you're 5 let's
say five nine and under 275 275 Jesus
that's a lot of weight maybe three max I
just like to get crushed what is it what
what did ramsey more what did he weigh
five 450 that a yeah somewhere right
around there by the way the best gigs
ever are comics memorials most people
just be off I was fun dude I was talking
about my biggest regret where Ramsay bar
that I never got through coke office
sweet kids
it was great dude it was so nice guy ah
UFC's gonna i'll know man this one's
gonna flop and they've had a lot of good
friends they released the numbers they
never released enough well granted I
don't know if I kind of get a little
sick of Dana right can I say that I feel
weird even saying that it's drop the
n-word so why not so I did I thought you
did earlier I don't think so okay dice
did dice did hard I'm getting some
little sick at Dana I'm sick of Dana
White I'm sticking hearing about the
Reebok deal I'm sick of him being
pompous and shitty to fans I get that
that's the kind of guy is and it's kind
of exciting to have like an anti Roger
Goodell kind of guy isn't so PC but he's
coming across I kind of a dick lately to
me I think when it was a brand stops
caring about what the fans think that's
when they start getting trouble a great
example is ESPN right now have you tried
to watch SportsCenter lately it always
is kid job cancer Birds all these kids
that have had cancer and he's it's a I'm
like what
I turned this on to watch highlights of
sports yeah and I got a tear in my eye
cause some kids getting chemotherapy are
in ken griffey jr. walks in the room and
changes his life do you know that ESPN
in the last calendar year has lost or
the last year excuse me has lost 3.5
million subscribers are you [ __ ] me
no it has one year it has but ESPN I
they've been cutting cutting all these
big names off there well it's a
competent and three point five million
subscribers subscribers
cable package they don't they've lost
all this because it's the most expensive
cable package this them going all-in on
the NBA has cost them a lot of money and
they've had to make cuts everywhere and
they say it's because of the price it is
unbearable to watch dude they're doing
stuff on the Special Olympics and you
study oh that's one thing but you're not
gonna like it's an event
you're basically mocking these guys Oh
Little Billy cakes don't bunch up they
literally do it like that oh look at how
hard he's running you're talking to like
a [ __ ] you're like you're mocking
these and how are you gonna beat a kid
in swimming that has three arms it's got
three arms it says a lot of them are
dropping cable to use the streaming
services well I use the streaming
service I don't have cable anymore and
their streaming service is a piece of
[ __ ] yes there's nothing on there
there's nothing [ __ ] on there it's
like it's the Pan Am Games or some
shitty like sprint car thing it's like
who gives a [ __ ] show me the real sports
like you it's just it's the worst
[ __ ] challenge I get to right now is
a bad time in sports why cuz it's only
baseball and you know nothing and golf
it's away from training cancer I
understand that but I'm saying the month
of July is generally okay but here's the
thing like I state like ESPN covers the
British Open okay and they had the
senior British Open last week and they
didn't even [ __ ] cover it there was
two hours of coverage a day that was it
after there was no live coverage so they
were never live except there was one
rain delay where they actually showed it
live but only because it was delayed
these [ __ ] sticks never do anything live
there it's a piece of [ __ ] company I
agreed during [ __ ] Hartford they
think they
they don't ever since hey Bob I got a
hartford go somewhere else
ever since ABC bottom and it's just been
it's crap it's like let's put pregnant
chicks on there
let's do sad stories and they used to be
one sad story
now it's multiple sorry a week ya know I
was like one Clive story ignore one
chemo we only get chemo once a week they
know what else they do that they didn't
do that made sports aren't really great
it's now they told you who won at the
beginning of highlight they used some
way to the end to be like Bob Allah
takes up Allah who wasn't they go
through the game and at the end they
tell you who won now they tell you
around fry you're like why am i watching
the rest of this [ __ ] high if I know
[ __ ] what I know why i watch i NHL
Network that's why I'm stuck on that
[ __ ] rest up I'm stuck is that how I
just got into it a couple years ago and
I and I just [ __ ] love it I got into
this year oh hey whoa Wow
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off sorry is there a girl
puckers up hey guys we should start of
go [ __ ] yourself podcast right war with
them but I gotta tell you there's
actually a mama as as sad and is
disappointing his golf usually isn't as
boring as it is I don't think rate great
[ __ ] story last week Robert Allenby
a stray lien player is is he's a hothead
he's a [ __ ] he was the guy who who
supposedly got mugged in Hawaii yeah so
this guy's he's [ __ ] insane yeah I
love it right he's the funnest he's
really honestly I'm not ready he was
actually at a strip he was really honest
and he got so [ __ ] up and I'd beat him
up well they claims that he was mugged
and then stuffed in a trunk of a car and
then they used his credit card to run up
all this money at a strip club when
later on it's kind of the clues are
still iffy but I think he went to the
strip club with these guys got all
[ __ ] up and then they just [ __ ]
rolled him it yeah tonight yeah and then
stuck him in the trunk of a car and
dumped him at the end of this yeah but
check this out so so last week he's
playing the first round of the Canadian
Open at Glen Abbey in in Toronto and I
actually caddy there a couple years ago
beautiful
in place and on this par 5 him and his
caddy are going back and forth and this
is a very veteran caddy and in alibies
been through about 20 caddies cuz he's a
[ __ ] hothead right and he and the guy
tells him a club whatever alibied dumps
it in the water on the 13th hole which
is his front nine and he calls him a fat
[ __ ]
he goes you fat [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
la the Caddy gets really pissed off it
actually goes over and talks to the
other two guys he goes what should I do
because I want to throw this [ __ ] bag
right in his face and they go just be
quiet finish the [ __ ] round
that's what you do that's professional
well they after the ninth hole Allenby
starts calling him a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
everything they [ __ ] go at each other
on the night behind the ninth green
stand each other's face he's like come
in the [ __ ] parking lot you piece of
[ __ ] who said Academy the Caddy says
this al amigos you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you won't [ __ ] talk to me like that
outside he goes go you know what go [ __ ]
yourself he drops the bag takes his bib
off and goes [ __ ] you I'm out of here
and the caddy [ __ ] walks off and then
and then so Allenby literally is
carrying his own bag with the bib
between the ninth and the you know the
18th and the first hole he's going to
play his back nine and some patron goes
you want me to you know if you need
somebody I'll carry your bag the guy
[ __ ] carried his back for him and and
the whole thing came out later like yeah
like Allenby actually tried to play it
off like like the caddy [ __ ] it was
was [ __ ] with him when that's when
like everybody else all the other
caddies everybody came out and go look
this is [ __ ] this is like the fifth
caddy you've been through this year
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] on this guy's like
reputation by saying he was doing this
you called him a fat [ __ ] and you
[ __ ] attack you were really verbally
attacking him and this whole thing
[ __ ] came to a head and I [ __ ]
love that [ __ ]
and it was so good I actually almost
[ __ ] texted Alem ego you need a caddy
for next I would love that dude you know
but love is numb I do I have his no no
this is not the British of this Canadian
Open PGA Tour but it was like it was a
big deal and and it's still out there
and and I don't know if he's playing
this way which ended up withdrawing from
the turn
he did so get that far huh
how's he making that [ __ ] so great
he's actually a really good guy mean
he's just he's had some issues in the
last year cocaine probably not a
cokehead likes that likes a little booze
and I think just he's had you know he's
had some issues
it's amazing you could drink all the
booze you want and never get in trouble
you are so long nobody's a golfer right
oh yeah maintain or any athlete if you
can maintain a level of production you
could drink blackout drink every night
you do a line of coke people like you
gotta go yeah yeah they changed the
rules actually the drug testing rules
were marijuana now is that you you
basically have to smoke a joint while
your piss testing to [ __ ] test
positive for what a lot of those golfers
smoke pot a lot of the guys do what is
the best pot sports Sunday night [ __ ]
dear Sunday nights Sunday nights when
the [ __ ] uh when the when the
tournament's over these guys are pulling
out of the [ __ ] parking lot in their
rental cars or their their courtesy cars
just smoke billowing out we have because
you only get drug tested on Thursday I
mean your tests are Thursday for they
can only test you during the tournament
so it's like you know you got a couple
days to [ __ ] word it off they just
fight they're just puffs and [ __ ] it out
the door okay for them yes to the victor
go the spoils
yeah what do you boil is exactly right
what are you thoughts on Mexicans Court
uh you were tell me last night how much
you hate him what were you saying
Mexican Koreans I hate Koreans on the
golf course
they're like 35-foot [ __ ] drivers and
they're not nineteen is not talk now
those are those seven best lightning rod
pair and they all have a [ __ ] staff
bag with their [ __ ] up name on it and
they [ __ ] pretend like they're
amazing and they suck [ __ ] balls
who are we talking about all Koreans
Asians on the golf course all Koreans
and they have to play the same - yeah
they're just as bad but to me the
Koreans are like [ __ ] dirty
cockroaches just all around a house
that's being condemned go to keep Minh
cotton can we get into the NFL I mean
we're two weeks away doing another thing
you're not gonna do it again re are you
guys I cannot believe the worst person
to win two weeks in two years in a row
is already any one of the three of us I
don't know if that means they have they
won a lot of games like a gate I thought
he's talking about a gay bar thank you
put that away
yeah
is what do you guys think about the
Cardinals hiring the first female let's
get into that no [ __ ] way
well first of all Bruce area is one of
the greatest football coaches the
nominees are [ __ ] right when he
coached the Colts when when when uh when
he was out with leukemia hell of a coach
and Bruce Arians [ __ ] coach that team
you knew to an amazing season you knew
he was getting uh you knew he was
getting a head coaching job oh he was
with the Ravens before I mean he wasn't
with areas with the Ravens before and
then he came over the Colts with Pagano
I mean he is a [ __ ] top-notch coach
so if he's hiring this chick to coach
you know he's fingering her my god
yeah I gotta think that there's that
this isn't a guy that's doing something
to hire the first female coach he's
hiring someone who's the best for the
[ __ ] she coach like some other kind
of pro football like a small early yeah
it wasn't like you're just getting an
analyst who's like you have no relation
to football she played semi-pro right
for females she plays she coached
so it's like he goes hey but look at
look at the [ __ ] Cardinals man they
were that considered I mean they were
the [ __ ] Raiders of the NFC for so
[ __ ] long where the shittiest [ __ ]
team ever the worst the worst [ __ ]
team just never errs and and all of a
sudden it's like another in Phoenix
everything off dude if lucky going to
Super Bowls
they're amazing doesn't go down last
year that guy that team is a legit
threat in the playoff 100 percent of
[ __ ] up the Seahawks they got a good
knee yeah and I love and I love that
it's the one stadium
that's indoor that's real grass they
actually take that fun I love it move it
outside everyday and water it and trim
it and then [ __ ] move it in game day
you got a great sax man like every day
at noon that that field slides out and
it just sits in the Sun and they can
maintain and then before the games so
like at 11:59 like 200 dogs just show up
and just wait for that grass to come on
I'll just start [ __ ] yeah well I I just
I think it I think if you're gonna look
and see that this guy this chick has
probably got some kind of training or
something that she's doing that's head
and shoulders above [ __ ] dude because
because it's it's you know moving
forward changing [ __ ] you know like
changing [ __ ] she's probably [ __ ] in
the forefront of her [ __ ] field and
it's like a bombs with as long as
they're the best you know Hollywood just
too much she warns people in just for
the sake of those people being is she
doing a job and she's okay with like re
- storyteller she'll I mean it's just no
chance of that I'm are being in your way
alright what if I do it look the reason
I say Armenians are among the worst of
the ones
hey I'm Native American or II can I do
it you gotta be at least half too late
Ari I'm a white middle oh what a man
what if I show up like just leaning
against the curb drunk that's not a half
Indian right there a dog a drinkin Mad
Dog do you see me playing cards falling
out of your pocket yeah I I know I have
friends at a casino does that help some
I'm Native American do they like
Mexicans nobody likes Mexico for some
reason no one's clamoring at all about
Asians no one gives a [ __ ] we don't have
a single issue because merchants don't
complain that's why that's it yeah cry
yeah except for that one chick with the
[ __ ] show and probably Comedy
Central's piss and agents cuz they
brought up that stupid thing that Susie
who or whatever her name was who didn't
get the [ __ ] joke that Colbert was
doing so she tried to start a social
movement then she had the balls to try
to do stand-up comedy it's a go [ __ ]
yourself
she tried to do it and I just hurt and a
bunch of Asians laughing at stupid Asian
jump did she have any funny jokes at all
did you see it like that show after real
quick does she like do you guys think
that guy after all the daily show is
good at all not watching him Michael che
yeah our Trevor um I met Trevor no no
yeah I like Larry I'm funny
yeah actually actually that is pretty
good show it is a good show I like I do
think I do think the round table at the
end I think the round table the end kind
of takes away because it's only some
issue and they have somebody who really
cares about the issue it's like that
just issue that's really complain about
that show yeah is that they don't have
enough comics on the panel saying we
don't need real experts you might need
people who are funny this isn't Bill
Maher yet up somebody who's gonna make
fun of yeah yeah yeah I agree that's
like they have the lesbian chick who
tried to AH she was a she's a CNN
correspondent and she tried to make that
cat calling into an issue but it blew up
in all their faces because they have
people go get have a great day they used
that as a cat call we're like that's cat
:
go [ __ ] yourself at 2 o'clock because
crackheads follow her down the street
and it's like of course they're gonna
follow her down the street yak head
David walk yeah walk through [ __ ]
Ari's neighborhood shaking your tits and
you're gonna [ __ ] people are gonna
follow you I'm just kidding you don't
live in a crack neighborhood I'm sure he
does no it's actually I like it I've
been of this village everybody being
hypersensitive it's like I can't like an
attractive woman walks down the street
and like and I just happen to yell hey
I'm gonna [ __ ] fist you and then I'm
gonna [ __ ] saw your head off you [ __ ]
and I was like woah catcalling no more
catcalling please right state I'm gonna
murder you and then I'm gonna [ __ ] you
before your body gets cold and now I'm a
[ __ ] dick
lighten up America we really do live
open we're saying whiten up America yeah
well thank you good point
lighten up America but I like what
you're saying lighten up why you wipe
our nothing could we take a moment do a
check-in on how teams doing with this
rainbow bracelets on what is yeah what
is that hey let's take your shirt off
idiot
No what's going on with the rainbow
bracelet why not I got cold air
conditioning work blood the shirts on
bit off at this point I'm a trendsetter
it's always black why do you say that
because I always see pictures of you
walking around the street you're sure
about sorry I'm not saying black Jews
don't have their shirt off I'm saying
when a white dude does have their shirt
off black people disperse I know why I
always walk around the streets of New
York with Ari with his shirt off there
was never any black people around that's
odd that you say that shirtless white
people I know why I know why black
people don't like that it's because they
think that it's asinine that we try to
get tan and like we feel like we look
better the darker we are but then we can
also be racist it's like how do you not
like how do you hate black people but
yet you're the one laying by the pool
trying to look black all the time racist
you all that's it all right you hate
racist if I get a really really really
good tan can I do that what this is not
happening show like it's got me really
I think about that I could I could I
could just carry it around male
comedians even guys are my friends like
if you get a vagina I can book you on
the show a hundred percent it won't even
be a question because your man because
you're a white man your top level here
enough to get on the show you're so
racial woman
I will 100% book you right now well okay
what if I get a really really [ __ ]
good tan what if I became a black woman
black face what if I became a black
woman if I became a black woman can I do
you like three minutes on your on your
TV show you're in I don't have to see
your story I don't have to see your
story okay over 12 years
she's in okay Oh what I want comedy for
12 years as a black woman though oh I
don't know maybe okay I'm still okay
okay we get into our last comic standing
predictions who do you think wins I
didn't I haven't seen it yet but I'm
gonna go ahead and say is there a [ __ ]
on the show no what's pretty good he's
funny
I wonder how long they wins most a woman
wins or an ethnic person wins or if
there's anybody that's like a [ __ ]
female at like Mexican there's a kid
that's going around doing snap right now
who's pretty he's a stud he got hit by a
ball yeah droolin she's I know him he's
a friend of mine from flappers he kills
yeah he's hilarious
he kills how do you think that would do
over an hour um I've seen him do a long
set and it's not bad I mean you know
obviously because you know he's got that
why stuttering well he he was a comic
before and then he was playing a company
baseball and an errant pinch hit him in
the throat so he was his voice was like
disabled and then now he like has a
stutter that he can't control oh that's
so yeah dude buddy - yeah he does he's
worked as stand-up now around the hill I
watched him a couple I went to Jay
Davis's fifth year anniversary of a show
last night
I was by went by there yeah and this kid
was on stage
let's see let's see what the guy looks
like the guy who stutters yeah and he's
getting a lot of like heat right now
yeah oh no everything on one second
start stuttering more so so so sorry
about that oh I've seen this guy yes yes
I've seen this guy he was on America's
Got Talent - OH
yeah it's like the kids making the
[ __ ] sympathy [ __ ] run yeah all
right all right but that's where we're
every now I mean yeah wha like Jules or
is it you can't be funnier like what's
your story
yeah all right
what have you overcome yeah my suicide
my pants a lot so that's gonna be
Michael yeah you should be the guy who
shits his pants come down he can't stops
no chicks won't button again I had a
roommate that used to [ __ ] his pants all
the time it it's one of the [ __ ] most
disgusting I had a roommate that used to
[ __ ] my pants that's worse yeah this guy
while I was wearing he was he shot in
the back of my pants just talking like a
top dresser drawer he was just pulling
my back of my dog this guy he would sit
low turns down my leg
he would be talking on the phone he go
eat golf soon he go oh my god I gotta
call you back I just [ __ ] my pants and
I'm like Oh times have you been [ __ ]
in the ass that you don't feel that
coming settle into your 40s
sometimes the farts become you know yeah
you know yeah you can't if you set it to
loose meal you can't trust you got the
first bubble fly your ass comes like a
magic trick
yeah what am I gonna pull out of my ass
at this point yeah is it afar or shat if
a little juice just drops you got to
pull away right I shouldn't anchor the
other day and here's the worst part
don't even remember eating an anchor the
first year of Last Comic Standing
yeah dad fair when Chris humor was in
full offense as it as a member consumers
walk yes of course
okay now those guys run the stand they
own and run the countless stand in New
York but Patrick Milligan
who's the Booker at the stand now who
was one of the founders of cringe humor
down the top ten before Last Comic
Standing started first year found out
who the top ten was and who the top
three were and printed it all and say
just so you know here's the top ten of
this contest Wow
before they even had the contest they
chose the last time yeah I don't think I
mean revealed it and said it's all a
sham some of these guys my friends even
everything on TV is a sham and everybody
forgot about it well it's amazing too
because that particular year dad fan won
against rich vos Kathleen Madigan
Ralphie May there was so many Todd glass
yeah I know see again but you're saying
that it's all voting Houska that's
[ __ ] who's counting the [ __ ] boat
it's all dummy come on there was stories
of Liza Schlesinger bombing in her
[ __ ] shows and still winning the ROM
was gonna win probably six weeks out
I knew she's gonna wait we made it into
the house they're Saints who lives like
just just be okay and we will let you
win
she's still the only woman to have won
it and there are funny they go we need a
woman Eliza's in she's pretty let's get
hurt they pretty much told her you're
going to win this thing I'm gonna go
with who's gonna win Miss Pat yep Oh
that'd be amazing if she won I'm gonna
put it in they don't have like a solid
list of all the comics out yeah I know
some of the people made it look I'm
looking at this Taylor Tomlin go that's
last year's rod man one last year funny
he's legit funny dude rod man is a funny
guy there's nothing funny for you no I
can't that's the best part
hey no don't do it I can't see it I
can't still catch it I'm blind I'm blind
rod man's funny again okay I can see you
I guess where we go with this rod man's
funny okay great oh so great I got a
love second that second City perfect all
right I got everyone Sarah Moore Tony
Baker Ian bagg Tony Baker Ian bagg both
very funny Shawn bad good Kevin Bozeman
Rhea butcher
Tony Carmen just Campbell rank honor
Alicia Cooper Dan Crowe
oh here's the name right here DC Irvin
what about the Taylor
Tomlinson she's in there she's funny
dude I don't think she ought indeed good
though I don't think she's gonna win it
but she doesn't have to she just gotta
make top ten but it's also it's also
things are like I've I know I feel like
she's never gonna be like you know her
barri let's take this call okay once you
Ron man is hey can you throw that up
we're coming gonna [ __ ] it up I'm not
sure who this is but I think I have a
good idea who this might be
hello you're on the air with punch-drunk
spool Josh Martin wants us to talk about
how the solely the jizz rag incident of
2013 with was it 13 2014 was ranked he's
controversy bottom line this guy washed
his face with our car and the bet has
been paid off John Hudson can't take
that yeah what did you want to do get a
time machine and go back and not have to
wash his face with our [ __ ] milk well
I think he wants to come the only fair
thing would be is if you were them that
mean beat up on all of your faces I
wasn't in charge of it I just took a
[ __ ] bag and pulled out wash your
face for our jets rack yeah and you made
the stupid bat dude don't even cry it
was a dumb bat and you lost the worst
way you could possibly lose I think we
have a medium I think we have a caller
that's not it too bad
caller are you there no I don't know
what you mean what do you mean you were
receiving the tech you were the one
getting text messages from this young
lady this woman I've ever seen
what do you mean some of the best
spreads oh wow we just saw re-spread one
just really brewed re-spread one of his
holes all right open your dick eye for
us no no before you give us an answer
make a dick hole talk Hey Ari's dick
hole how's it going [ __ ] in your dick
hole are you know something car key and
see if it'll hold it in there jam it all
the way in and then start your your dick
like a car put a piece of candy in there
and then eat it yeah yeah car becomes
new album coming out live for Pearl
Street available on iTunes it does sound
a lot like little hobo let's call your
puppet your dick little home on that is
now burned into my mind that's so nice
August 7th it's out right now for
presale it's called live from Pearl
Street Court yeah how long is it court
it's about 55 minutes perfect
that's right under an hour that's great
yeah GSB how's your comedy career been
going last time you called in you almost
had one minute he wants to do kill Tony
but he only had 35 seconds of comedy
really do you haven't eaten any new bits
you could run by us
this is our most offensive podcast yeah
it's really I'm glad I could be a part
of what about your Tony Hinchcliffe
impression I'm sure Court would like to
hear that one time Walter of the world
does a pretty good impression
Georgia's waiting for us at Montreal
waiting for you to do it I mean I would
have a perfect place would have been to
do it George say can I ask you something
George what is your take on Hulk Hogan
ah we want to hear I mean you obviously
love so wrestling are you a little hurt
by him dropping the n-bomb that sounded
and is re-watching ari take a piss
what why do you encourage this not
encourage you he starts pissing and then
lower what's that sound what'd you do
don't go chasing waterfalls [ __ ] up his
dick and you don't describe interesting
with thirsty eyes I don't have the eyes
it's awesome
thirsty [ __ ] eyes watching re peach
alright describing what's going on for
listeners at home yeah because I can't
watch you just stand there with thirsty
[ __ ] eyes I had a few of our fans in
San Fran says what comes up to me and
say you know what thank you for always
describing Arnie's [ __ ] because we can't
see it
and we want to see it I've actually
heard that a few times people have
messaged me like hey work on the video
so we can see his day exactly people
feel left out that they can't see your
Wang so I'll describe that you're
talking your lips the whole time is it
going on that's exactly what I did right
there how would you know he was alright
I want to say thank you some guys come
up to the door guys invade us all we
don't work gave you what we eat at work
yeah you lost your toe yep yes when did
you lose your toe you go until about two
weeks ago I almost had to amputate his
whole head no did you lose
just play that into your [ __ ] out got
the ugliest balls in town come they got
stuck on a car seat before they flatten
it out we've talked more about our ease
dick and [ __ ] then we have about
sports on this podcast today yeah
sometimes that happens no I said July is
a weak time in sports re do you think
that the re do you think the Dodgers
trade Puig I mean because he's not
playing that well he's got name value
and he doesn't get along with teammates
that's the reason yeah I could see it I
could see it I mean you gotta do now
before you know three seasons from now
and everybody realizes that you know he
ain't as good as people think he is you
know yeah that's that's a great analogy
Ari that's exactly what run two years
ago yep and he's been living off that
now he hasn't done he's just like I got
paid and I don't I'm not gonna perform
it he just doesn't take it serious I
think he's more concerned with being on
SportsCenter and highlights and talked
about than he is putting in a consistent
you know nine to five work ethic just
play good always diving for balls when
you don't need to always trying to make
these crazy foot he's like a [ __ ]
like 12 year old show off in a little
bit game sorry let me I'm a big Charlie
six runs like who's gonna take that I'm
gonna name their buyer's or seller's of
what of whether they're buying free
agents are selling free agents okay okay
here we go the New York Mets selling
them soon selling okay they just got
somebody yeah
they just picked up somebody they're
kind of still into I think they would
have lost to the Dodgers they would have
gotten rid of them but I think they they
kind of got a couple games there yeah I
think the divisions up for grabs is
reduced so you're like buyers Twiggs
salaries four point five million dollars
that's nothing in baseball what do you
think they need they need bats or any
pitchers have no idea they need bats
they need bad they got that they have a
couple I mean degrom is great they're
young pitchers have really shown up dude
they all look like like to see the Mets
make a run I'd like to see that too not
freeze your period traits traits yeah
yeah exactly that's what they call fires
so either you're trying to get guys yeah
right now it's like I mean really it's
like ultimately like who's gonna make
that final push and try to make a run
we're gonna go next one next one the
Detroit Tigers selling they've already
said they're selling they're selling
everything there's three games out of a
wild card
yeah but that's a lot that they're fames
out of the wild card okay and they're
down to a lot of teams are down to Tampa
Bay Ultima worth of Blue Jays Baltimore
glued is above under playing and it wins
the Blue Jays make a run the Blue Jays
will make a run to me I still say the
Blue Jays the best Ino Blue Jays have
scored more runs of anybody else to like
they they just have shitty pitching yeah
I know the Blue Jays know their runs
against is not even that bad they have
433 runs against that they're in the
same position as pretty much the Yankees
they they blend up 15 more runs the
Yankees over the whole season Jace is
the most underrated team in the AL I
think they're gonna come away with al if
not the AL East
I mean definitely a wild card but just
watch the Blue Jays they're the second
best seem to me they talk about
I think that's amazing
zerrin Toronto is looking to get troy
tulowitzki from the Rockies no they did
get them there he got them did they yeah
there's time I've looked at the baseball
standings they're angels buyer's or
seller's mmm I'm probably sellers I
guess know what handed hitting outfit
sellers if they're buyer's or seller's
its buyers okay moves they already they
got they got Shane Victorino yes
Victorino from Boston huh yeah he's been
he's been on the DL twice he's only
hitting like 255 what's up with the
Boston Red Sox they won during the World
Series two years ago and then the bottom
just fell off they suck it's amazing is
that manager good or bad the 13 games
out behind the Yankees 100 games in hey
Ari that's a lot would you vote for Alex
Rodriguez for MVP if they make a run for
the MVP do you think that the that Major
League Baseball Writers would ever allow
that to happen though he's nothing
Yankees MVP he's third or fourth in the
Yankees his o-p-s isn't as good to share
us his his hitting is not as good as
gardeners his pitching I mean his
pitching is all its carrying them how
can you make him an MVP when he's gonna
hit 275 I'm just throwing it out there
scenarios
okay I'm telling you that he doesn't
have the stats for that I mean if you're
talking about if you got the 300 yet 40
home runs with a Ben Vaughn form I think
they might I think there's a couple guys
who are gonna be crotchety about it and
not forgive him still but I think they
might but he's not in a position Panetta
is better than
look at CeCe's not but no one's better
than I mean everybody's better Betances
is better than him Wilson's better than
him he's like 7th best player on their
team right now
Ariana these three teams who makes the
playoffs Baltimore Orioles New York
Yankees Toronto Blue Jays stepping up
the Orioles I think they're a great team
manager achieved us here and I don't
think they put it together I think it's
I mean the Yankees have a seven-game
lead with 60 games left that's pretty
big because of that I'll give it to the
Yankees but if there was 75 games left I
give it to the Blue Jays oh you got a
boner for these Blue Jays let's see
you're living in New York too long or
too close to Canada great Montreal is
it's all about Canada I just kids back
from Canada you can't get that kid a
dick out of it
ari does Jason Tebow's Cubs make the Lea
make the playoffs I think it started
today the Cubs get in yeah they'd be a
wild card they would be a wild if they
started today the Cubs would get in they
pretty sure there would be a wild card
no two and a half games ahead of them
not in first place yeah they're two and
a half games okay our black listeners
Sactown blue wants a fast San Francisco
Giants buyer's or seller's I think it's
obvious they're buyers they're buying
they're just made a big run they've
almost pretty much caught the Dodgers
four on everything it's like they're
playing great right now that won six in
a row 9 in the last 10 the Dodgers
should be in real trouble they should be
really worried they coasted without
without separating from the rest of the
division you've got a moving outfielder
if you're the Dodgers you've got a
moving outfielder you got to get a
better frontline pitcher we did we
didn't do a last year David price that
blew up in our [ __ ] face we got to
get a [ __ ] go get Cole Hamels give up
everybody except for them hogs are
trying to get him to give up to
everybody except for that number one
prospect we have a shortstop anybody
else get [ __ ] give it up I mean grief
he's amazing Kershaw's amazing yeah you
need a third guy I mean yes I think you
just pick up this mic and like chug a
[ __ ] I know it's so good just like we
did last year
[ __ ] spiders do look similar to last
year to me we always use set up guys
because you don't want to make any major
changes move some guys it's time the
windows 17 saves that's was leaving your
team's saves he got hurt for a while
though dude yes 17 more saves that re
you got hurt for a while see this saves
between even games okay
something but still that then somebody
else should be leading that yeah you
know I mean yeah we need to get them go
we need to move some guys we need to get
Vince like out there to play every day
ya know I don't know what are we doing
with uh with the fantasy league this
year you are component of I do not want
a fourteen team League I don't want
fourteen team League I like I like the
twelve team so you want to cut it down
to twelve are your thoughts on this as
the defending champ don't know what the
difference between 12 and 14 team league
14 League has 14 people in it and a 12
has obviously 12 less players to pick
from listed players of each team well it
what it really means is less good
players on the waiver wire is nothing
what T by always does and I love Tebow
he goes e drafts all the running backs
so there's no running backs left for
anybody maybe I do maybe I don't I don't
know I just
that's not my strategy going in but I
draft whatever I drop I think Laster had
better receivers and running backs I 12
teams
I just think 12 teams are more fun you
could pick up people you get more
competitive league I'm into that no 10
teams is like it's too stupid water Civ
all you do I need you to like 300 teams
and everybody just gets one player see I
think that would be [ __ ] fun that
would be [ __ ] fall it is just super
low scoring but I mean it's it's all
it's all relative 32 teams I think
that's great then your value I don't
really I would love that GSP what there
is a CFL course there is
that's why he left now you've had some
experiences yes he left because he back
no he quit then he came back but a lot
of a lot of the players are our times
dammit Mako we'll give you a nicer
locker room with a net okay I come back
I want that dude I wish you to create
your own fantasy leagues and we could do
the WNBA that beast I guarantee you
there is one there isn't we've looked it
up
there's has to be one no there's a WNBA
fantasy league there is no fantasy
involved I bet your NBA so my tribe your
NBA fantasy league involves me just
sitting in a shower a chain-smoking and
[ __ ] my fist while these gargoyles
soap up their jugs
there is a fantasy that's what they're
bringing back there good join with my my
first pick I want that one black lesbian
you want a tall black Lesbia okay at all
my second pick look at that other black
lesbian yeah don't that's goes a lot
there's no dude I would do that in a
heartbeat a fancy and WNBA fancy I know
that actually yeah there is yeah I've
know you can join up for it now but yeah
yeah course you can we did the WNBA
start it starts as ready at the end of
the NBA season dari if you think about
it right because if lack of talent and
strength Novak saves hell but they get
screwed because nobody wants to go
indoors during the summer like you play
you play a lot of comedy clubs once the
worst time to play like a cold area
comedy club during the summer yeah of
course nobody wants to go indoors they
all will be outdoors so nobody's gonna
go watch a WNBA game during the summer
because everybody wants to be outdoors
that's why you're amazing for those they
paper the the the arenas can't even
paper a [ __ ] you paper an MBA a WNBA
game it goes three rows back I'm
I'm tell you this if you go to a WNBA
game and right before the game starts
right after the national anthem you go
quick question everyone who actually
paid for their tickets few hands go up
few few lesbians and they're holding
hands and they hold up their hands
together in unity you see they're
leather red who got free who got free
tickets from Carl's jr. or whatever
alright Lee the local car wash everybody
raises their [ __ ] hands it's free
[ __ ] to do that's who's at that [ __ ]
Arena ticket free parking free
everything yeah thanks free that we
marry hot dog night it's free hot dog
night over at the [ __ ] UH Tampax
[ __ ] Stadium we're in the Kansas City
Kansas City Kotex Arena
wherever our over at forever 21 field
the Kansas City Kotex arena you got Zack
Lee I mean how much money are [ __ ]
tampon companies making that you you
have a product they have to buy yeah you
know you got no [ __ ] you got no choice
being either that or it's just
disgusting pillows your pillows you got
a big enough plot just use pillows it's
[ __ ] terrible the ass [ __ ] couch
cushion she's bleeding again where's my
couch cushion added [ __ ] [ __ ] wife
of mine big ass two-car garage she calls
her [ __ ] he's bleeding again
of course DSP your team a would call it
yeah your teammate hasn't called in a
while wait I think she's I think she's
on the other line right now hang on
she's calling in right now are you there
Ahri's old roommate that played the fur
you men from Maryland basketball right
man bass and you used to play ball yeah
you should get beat up by the women's
team when you played for the women's
Terrapins towns would you ever with the
team ever force all ready to eat your
[ __ ] yeah then you ate a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ari come on come on
towns did the team ever blow bang Ari
just y'all just make em eat your mouth
scare you when he had his shirt off
we're trying to figure this out there
even uneven back then good
Wow what do you think might have gone
down in there with re coming out of a
bathroom limping with another gentleman
where do you also guy wear skinny jeans
yes you have fallen off the map since
you was a woman basketball player re oh
that's great well thank you for calling
so much we love you
can I just say that's nice tan with like
the Cookson [ __ ] okay we have never seen
anything like that what are you in what
sense forget about the flamboyance but
also include the flamboyance I've never
seen another flip not flameboy a play on
the NBA and I've never seen anyone who's
that amazing just defense and rebounding
oh yeah he was getting 25 it was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's long numbers before
that was I mean after that was Ben
Wallace and to a point was ah I'm not
nobody's been that flamboyant who tried
to do the polarizing character yeah he's
really smart he's like dude I gotta find
a niche
and I mean you look at his rebounding
numbers and it's like yeah Emily like
18.7 average per game that's nuts
yeah brain essentially 20 that for his
career I mean he I mean I mean he went
he went between 16 in his last two years
last year with the Bulls he was at 16
point 1 and his height was eighteen
point seven with the Pistons but I mean
in between there he still was like 17 he
never dropped below like 16 I mean oh my
god yes some games where he was getting
an upper 20s of rebounds in a game yeah
you like that he just yeah he was great
at doing the dirty work for a team you
know when he was with the Lakers he
played 13.1 with his career average yeah
that's high he led the league one two
three you know row not in his career in
a row or essentially a decade he led the
NBA in rebounding that was that's that's
that's crazy yeah he was also a wrestler
oh yeah he didn't know that he was in a
movie you know you wrote a book he's
some cocaine [ __ ] with Malone [ __ ]
with him it was great he was dead
Georges comes in and Jason Bohn do you
think the whole time he's trash-talking
Malone going listen you want do some
lines and blow ass for you was that he
never wore a cup so when he posted when
when he guards you from behind he would
grind his junk on you that's Chris
Webber used to talk about it that's Hari
would do you put his [ __ ] junk right
in your ass did he say he had a monster
dick dude he's a black MBA yeah but you
know he's here Shaq had a small dick
you've heard us that's true
so I mean you know every black guy
doesn't have a monster dick no they do
all taste good do you know what the
biggest one I think I said this before
Scottie Pippen supposedly had in the
room
but even the other black guys are like
oh my god
I mean he's he had the worst his nose
he's so recognizable because he had that
[ __ ] like just that weird like big
[ __ ] car you know you imagine being
in an NBA locker room and having a
shower around these [ __ ] anacondas
and you just got this white dick that's
just over there you got a mark price no
you got a mark Price [ __ ] and
everybody's got a [ __ ] Rodman why is
this Christ you're just like you feel
safe John Paxson and you're just washing
your little [ __ ] dump oh god you're
gonna scrub your little [ __ ] turtle
head of a dick and now everything around
you looks like it's like these vines
just hanging down
really you got eggs is dicks they have
like owls nest in them is anybody
interesting calling I don't think so
now you never know are we coming to an
it when we got six minutes ah what do we
got what are we waiting for the NFS the
name of this podcast today I don't know
you because you're sure I would call it
for you we call hail the gang's all here
cuz it's been the first time in a while
that we had a full studio and everybody
was here and it was all good sure sure
sources versus kids that's good too I
like that shirt versus skins shirt shirt
versus all right yeah that's really
creative guys we really created
something right there I feel [ __ ]
amazing I'm gonna blow my [ __ ] brains
out I feel so goddamn good all right can
you see us yeah okay no because the
screen is different
I didn't that's fine well you're fine
with that it's been fun you really want
to wrap this up huh it's a real treat
getting to see all three you guys in one
place ago my buddy court McCowan's new
CD everybody
live from Pearl Street live from pearls
yeah that's great that sounds [ __ ] it
but sounds like a [ __ ] Memphis it's
great it sounds like live from Beale
Street but listen not an insult it's
just cool
yeah dude British Open we didn't talk
about this how exciting was that
[ __ ] dude I was just looking at
this thing is so unreal and the fact
that Jordan was there I got he blew it
at the end I know history I know he blew
it but they just they just thought I'm
so sick of the Jesus Jack Zach Johnson
but I just Pulis Jordan speith just had
his 22nd birthday all right this is
insane 22 years old 22 years old and
they were talking about like a little
comparison to him and Tiger Woods and
and it's like woods when Woods is 22 is
career earnings were 2.7 million and
Spieth are just over eighteen point four
million unbelievable
but Woods was number one in the world at
the time by age 22 and Spieth is number
two but it's like it's weird that like
who's number one right now a Rory
McIlroy but I say this is awesome a kid
I say that what's going on a golf right
now is the greatest resurgence of in
history I mean since Tiger Woods came
around and those who's gonna have quite
a rivalry for a very not just those two
there's a lot of [ __ ] Patrick
Reed there's so many guys there's so
many guys that are so close yeah but I
mean you have Elise kayaking Paula
Gretzky Dustin Johnson who's another guy
who's [ __ ] unbelievable I mean
there's so many guys Brooks koepka
Rickie Fowler all these guys that are
there now that Golf is in a place where
it's never been before yeah because when
Tiger was in it I don't give a [ __ ] what
everybody says yes he was the greatest
golfer at that time sir but the
competition was nothing like it
he was HT aging can we agree to that yes
hunter I mean I don't know if he was
aged but he was just above he was he was
doing roids or some something he was
just he became this big this is a
monster he was Mike Tyson
he was my type nobody could fight nobody
was every others afraid of Tiger Woods
juicing he wouldn't he won the US
Amateur 150 pounds yeah yeah but after
that like the last five its like Barry
Bonds Barry Bonds was a Hall of Famer
before he started juicing yeah Danny
juicy became the super monster
Tiger Woods had all the skills to win
without it but at some point he just
went [ __ ] nuts
and you started look at this guy who's
built like a Navy SEAL benching fourth
yeah Lance Armstrong and he just dude
that explains why his body has
completely broken down and that's why he
can't do anything anymore it's like a
baseball player you take him off the
juice their game just falls off Nike
should get him a CH blow hookers
vicodins whatever he wants just to get
him back because he needed all that
today I'm not saying all the neat Tiger
Woods anymore let's see the whole thing
that don't think everybody's missing
about this whole thing is jordan Spieth
what's so amazing about this kid not
only did he win his first tournament at
19 but he's 22 years old and he's not
that I mean there's nothing like like
Tiger he hit it further than everybody
then he put this guy is just so [ __ ]
all-around good in his mentality reinder
and he's a [ __ ] grinder man and I
[ __ ] I we got to I got to play with
him when we're at Greenbrier the week
before he won his first term he's 19
years old we placed two rounds with him
when I was caddying for Parnevik and at
the end of the two rounds we go like
what's the big talk about we're like we
don't even get like why does everybody
think this kid's so good we go oh he's
7-under par he just [ __ ] just sneaks
up on you and he's so [ __ ] good
he's gonna be around forever he is gonna
surpass all that everybody's ever done
he's gonna beat Nicholas he's gonna beat
everybody this kid is good that's this
kid's the real deal yeah there you go
all that drama oh that amateur almost
winning it money but here's the deal
I'll tell you this right now always been
against the amateur going into the
fourth round it happens all the time
they make a good run but then the eyes
are on them
have to go to bed at night and they've
never gone to bed at night with the
[ __ ] British open for the US Open on
the title and they always shoot like
five over par that day why he was he was
one he was one putt he was one putt away
from from tying it up that's all I can
say on the 17th hole hmm jordan Spieth
unless beat there was a future oh yeah
[ __ ] the amateurs in every good buddy
when did you take this call Oh tall you
want me to Dean Doug am okay I didn't
hang up oh yeah I wanna suck it did be
talking about Jordan [ __ ] Spieth rock
and [ __ ] roll the best when he come
back he sounded so sad when yeah you're
on with Dean [ __ ] Dell [ __ ] ray on
the Dell [ __ ] razors who needs a [ __ ]
side he goes goddamn it he called it
that our battery's running low
all right let's wrap it up where you
gonna be what do you got and then n
burrow for all of August also shrimp
Fest is coming up August 29 30 31st
get your mushrooms now do your mushrooms
August 29th 30th and 31st wherever you
are all right man see you guys next
Thursday August 6 at the W Hotel in
Hollywood aha W Hollywood hotel for the
naughty show with Joe Rogan Steve
Rannazzisi Tiffany Haddish and uh mr.
Cota and leigh styles and course myself
Tebow will be there we'll make some
magic ass suck suck suck it ah I'll be
at the Comedy Store tomorrow do a NICU
SEFs new material show and I'll be at
the ice house Friday and court please
get a CD where can they get it talk
about it go to iTunes go to all you can
check it out it should be a link on all
things comedy go to court McAllen calm
just go on iTunes search court McAllen
CO RT MCC o WN live from Pearl Street
thank you very much and I'm battling Kim
Kong tonight in the Rose
all right suck it